it starts with the 22 lives that were
taken
but the effects of what happened have
been horrendous
for so many others then he killed us
losing me son of it it's just
june's son phillip and his partner's
daughter courtney boyle
were both killed in the manchester bomb
you know they just didn't get it right
they should have
they didn't communicate with each other
they just didn't communicate with each
other
and that's where that's where it comes
down now and the need to
all need to work together
you know it's no good than being one
here and one there and one elsewhere and
not knowing what the other one's doing
we've got to work together and i think
that's part of the blame
for over an hour and a half the suicide
bomber loitered around the ariana grande
concert with his large
heavy backpack he bears ultimate
responsibility
with his brother who helped build the
bomb but
others failed too i was urged by
everybody
to avoid looking for scapegoats
i have not looked to blame anyone
but where having considered the evidence
i consider that individuals have fallen
below a proper standard
in carrying out their important roles in
protecting consequences
at 10 15 that night a member of the
public christopher wire was waiting to
pick up his 14 year old daughter
from the concert he told a security
guard muhammad aga
there's a suspicious person sat behind
you he's got a backpack
but instead of being taken seriously mr
wilde felt
fobbed off at 10 23 mohamed agar did
speak to his colleague
kyle lawler and explained the situation
but mr lawler
couldn't get through to the control room
on his radio
at 10 30 concert goers were streaming
out of the arena salman abadi left his
hiding place
and a minute later detonated his bomb
he could and should have been challenged
salmon abedi may still have detonated
his bomb
but if the security had worked lives
could have been saved
the doors into this area could have been
closed
meaning fewer not
[Laughter]
his mother available now this inquiry
too want to see venue operators
compelled by
law to take responsibility it would mean
that people can go to concerts and enjoy
the freedom that this country offers
with the knowledge they're going to come
home that night and and what can be more
important
you know so our loved ones didn't have
that privilege unfortunately
this city's sense of security was
shattered that night
nothing changes the facts but the people
who had their lives altered forever
and the 22 people who died deserved
better
tom parmenter sky news manchester